>>> HAPPENING TODAY, THE
CONSERVATIVE POLITICAL ACTION
CONFERENCE ON CPAC KICKS OFF IN
TEXAS.
NOW, THE USUAL SPEAKERS WILL BE
THERE, DONALD TRUMP, STEVE
BANNON, TED CRUZ AND SO ON, BUT
SO WILL A CONTROVERSIAL FOREIGN
LEADER, HUNGARY'S VIKTOR ORBAN
WHOSE GOVERNMENT IS ACCUSED OF
UNDERMINING WOMEN'S RIGHTS, LGBT
RIGHTS, CONTROLLING THE MEDIA
AND MUCH MORE.
CNN'S BEN WEDEMAN IS LIVE IN
BUDAPEST.
BEN.
>> Reporter: JOHN, DESPITE ALL
OF THAT EVEN THE CRITICS OF THE
PRIME MINISTER HERE CONCEDE THAT
OVER THE LAST 12 YEARS SOME OF
HIS POLICIES HAVE MANAGED TO
HELP IMPROVE THE LOT OF MANY
HUNGRINESS, YET DESPITE THAT OF
LATE AS THE ECONOMY HAS BEGUN TO
FALTER VIKTOR ORBAN HAS RESORTED
TO RHETORIC REMINISCENT TO SOME
OF HIS DARKEST DAYS IN THIS
COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
YOU COULD CALL IT A MEETING OF
LIKE MINDS, VIDEO FROM HIS
OFFICIAL -- DONALD TRUMP TUESDAY
AT HIS BEDMINSTER, NEW JERSEY,
GOLF CLUB.
ON HIS WAY TO THIS WEEK'S
CONSERVATIVE POLITICAL ACTION
CONFERENCE IN TEXAS.
THE HARD RIGHT ANTI-IMMIGRANT
PRIME MINISTER RECENTLY SET OFF
ALARM BELLS WITH HIS SPEECH
LACED WITH SINISTER UNDERTONES.
WE EUROPEANS, ORBAN SAID, ARE
WILLING TO MIX WITH ONE ANOTHER
BUT WE DO NOT WANT TO BECOME
PEOPLE'S OF MIXED RACE.
HE HAS SINCE COME OUT INSISTING
HE ISN'T RACIST OR ANTI-SEMITIC.
THE DAMAGE, HOWEVER, IS DONE.
VICTOR ORBAN'S TALK ABOUT RACIAL
MIXING, ABOUT RACIAL PURITY STIR
UP DARK, STILL FRESH MEMORIES.
THESE METAL SHOES COMMEMORATE
THE SPOT WHERE IN THE FINAL
MONTHS OF WORLD WAR II HUNGARIAN
NAZIS MURDERED THOUSANDS OF
JEWS.
IT'S TIME FOR EVENING PRAYER IN
BUDAPEST'S HISTORIC SIYNAGOGUE.
THIS RABBI SAID ORBAN'S WORDS
HIT TOO CLOSE TO HOME.
>> WE SAW THIS SMALL
CONGREGATION HERE, WHO COME HERE
EVERY EVENING, EVERY MORNING TO
PRAY, THEY ARE OLDER PEOPLE.
MOST OF THEM ARE HOLOCAUST
SURV
SURVIVORS.
AND THEY ARE WORRIED.
THEY HEARD THIS BEFORE.
AND IT DIDN'T END WELL.
>> Reporter: OFTEN DESCRIBED AS
AN AUTHORITARIAN, ORBAN HAS BEEN
IN POWER FOR THE LAST 12 YEARS,
REELECTED IN APRIL.
HIS ECONOMIC POLICIES HAVE WON
HIM SUPPORT, BUT WITH INFLATION
RISING THAT'S BEGINNING TO
CHANGE, SAYS THIS ECONOMIST.
>> IN THE LONGER RUN, YES, I
THINK ORBAN REMAINS POPULAR, BUT
AT THIS PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME
I THINK PEOPLE ARE MORE
SKEPTICAL THAN EVER BEFORE.
>> Reporter: IN THE CENTRAL
MARKET OPINIONS VARY.
THE BUTCHER BEGS TO DIFFER.
VICTOR ORBAN IS DOING EVERYTHING
FOR HIS PEOPLE, SHE SAYS, HE
LOVES HIS PEOPLE.
EVENING AND CITY RESIDENTS SAVER
THE SOFT BREEZES OFF THE DANUBE,
HISTORY FLOWS THROUGH THIS CITY,
THE FAST NEVER FAR FROM THE
SURFACE.
AND WITH A POSSIBLE RECESSION ON
THE HORIZON THE FEAR IS THE
PRIME MINISTER IS LOOKING FOR
SCAPEGOATS, SOMETHING THIS PART
OF EUROPE HAS SEEN IN THE PAST.
JOHN?
>> BEN WEDEMAN LOOKING AT
LIBERAL DEMOCRACY AND THE ECHOS
OF HISTORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.